you guys love when on the main channel i
put four people in a red circle and had
him duke it out for ten thousand dollars
it was intense
so now we're gonna redo it but this time
in minecraft blocks
i will explain the rules but first
server disperse
and the circle is going to slowly shrink
like this until they meet in the middle
and whoever of these minecraft players
is the last remaining
wins ten thousand dollars turn pvp on
let the battles begin
oh it's on dude people target us they're
literally going after me
oh my god oh so far eight people have
died and the circle's barely shrugged
i'm taking blocks from people
oh oh shoot if you hold down shift
nobody can see your name i got a now eye
over here let's go are you shooting me
well
how about this uh-huh yeah how about you
think twice about shooting me
a shame if somebody came by and just
took some chunks out of bases
like our typical challenges first place
gets 10 grand this one i want to do
something different
second place also gets a honda civic oh
but you get a honda civic that's under
10 grand yeah all right you get a 9
999 honda civic all right i got two on
me i got two army i'm chasing one
one's behind me oh he just flanked yep
you're dead
oh my gosh this is actually intense's
haunt dude why does everyone hate me
go after each other oh oh they're
attacking oh
now he's going on the offense oh i knew
it i freaking knew it i literally
freaking knew it vendetta
come here chandler's angry he's like the
hulk when he gets mad he gets powerful
can you move uh juice four two zero
sixty nine he's got funny numbers in his
name
and two here what up juice for twenty
sixty nine what's up
why are you hiding because i'm scared do
you even know what you're competing for
i have no idea first place gets ten
thousand dollars i like that
second place gets a honda civic that's
nine thousand nine hundred ninety nine
dollars
i also like honda civics and third place
gets a dollar a dollar wouldn't be bad
okay we'll just give you the dollar
you can leave anything you want to say
while tons of people are watching i mean
i want that though
oh you should probably say hey i'm about
to die nah it's okay they're distracted
oh look at this guy he's also hiding
what is this the campy corner over here
oh my gosh i haven't seen carl the whole
game where are you
i can help you where are you right here
right here okay perfect let's get this
number on let's go
there's one hit let's go
somebody sniped him oh somebody just
sniped his kill
this guy just absolutely sniped that
don't forget while all this fighting is
going on the circle is still shrinking
very soon
it's going to collapse on the middle ooh
like it's deteriorating too
oh yeah i'm on you boy i'm on you
got him yeah where are you going yeah
where are you running now
watch out got him let's go oh i got full
inventory of bodies
larry larry my neighbor is mowing his
yard larry stop
classic if you hear background noise
blame larry you have a stack of blocks
two stacks all right let's make a base
now here we go oh the circle's
getting smaller i'm going into the abyss
wish me luck
hello everybody hello hi i just realized
i forgot to tell you what you're
competing for
winner gets 10 grand all right second
place gets a honda civic worth 99999
dollars what's that evening
i don't know third place gets a dollar
in approximately two minutes we're gonna
drop op stuff in the middle
have fun also stop killing chandler
you're making him sad
all right let's make a base let's make a
base right here let's make this one ours
oh it's eight block you can't even go
eight blocks up
what the heck who's hitting me dude they
targeted me off the jump and i have to
get an
all they're about to kill him i have to
get an all account
why chandler run he's gonna kill you
here's the timer when it hits zero drop
op stuff where is it at uh the timer
yeah it's right there oh no no right
here silly
not above you above me you're just
faking chris is a faker
you caught me i'm a faker yeah it's
above carl's head too oh
whoa they saw my name i uncrouched and
they saw my name it's over
it's over guys
i know there's a timer above my head but
the problem is i can't currently see it
i'm just gonna assume it hits zero
challenge drop some stuff
okay boots dude there's helmets does no
one want it oh oh we gotta take her
i guess hop hop waffle xx is just gonna
grab it because everyone's like nope
hot waffle all right well this guy got
full dive well
here's the worst part is we got a bunch
of weenies look at yeah this guy right
here nico's is being a weenie hut junior
this guy's got a whole a whole base
to the viewers at home imagine competing
in this competition you're just running
around look at everyone everywhere in
all the bases while the circle is
shrinking
this is intense
you're bad can the car arc just be over
hey tp to me this guy took over my base
so i'm rooting for him to win
that was a love tap no he misconstrued
my love tap
i mean it was it was with the sword yo
chris
chris i found big c big c big c
hey who's shooting at big c over here oh
boy jedi shooting at big c don't tell
big c but with their zone shrinking he
might actually die here soon
oh no all right let's see oh that was
close he jumped right at the right time
look at that they all ran away they're
like all right nevermind what a boss
he had 19 health he got him down to six
big cities getting the mats
oh oh we got a camper up here oh big c
doesn't see them oh there's not a lot of
people left let me get a bird's eye view
as you can see the circles
circle the circle what's a circle oh
guys a circle
now that we got that out the way the
circle is getting very small look at it
whoa oh it's about to get a lot smaller
like that's like 25
of it oh my gosh is it gonna get any of
these noobs out oh big c
is archery skills are showing off this
game everyone just got 64 more wool
blocks
it's about to be a build-off oh i
suggest giving everybody flint and steel
for the wolf i like it carl
blind steal everybody yeah big break
you know what i'm gonna start lighting
stuff on fire oh yeah let's do it yeah
we're gonna give everyone diamond armor
to make this a little bit more fair
there are 12 players remaining guys
10 players oh my gosh two people just
died 10 players were made
burn the wall oh and the zone is
shrinking
oh my gosh things are getting chaotic
pixi's going for the kill
he's going back with the full diamond
big c dude put your diamond on
jimmy check this out i'm putting another
sword in the middle
and then watch when somebody runs for it
he's coming he's coming
oh he goes he came from behind me he
came from behind me
nine players remain hasn't boy jedi won
a challenge before
yeah like two or three all right here
i'm putting a bounty on him five
thousand dollar bounty
five thousand oh look at him look at him
they all turned and went towards jenna
oh no boy jenna all right sorry yo he is
good he's doing pretty good i'm not
gonna lie credit where credit's dude boy
jedi is a champion
oh big c is cutting them off thinks he's
cutting them off whoever kills him gets
the prize
seven health oh jenna oh wait who got it
who's
who's delivering the blow oh oh he he
knocked pixie off wait but who got the
kill was it zoom
zoom zoom wait so big c died for nothing
dang he fell move zooms in the coal
sorry big c we love you also sorry boy
jedi
i got him i got boy jedi yeah you did
congratulations zooms you just won
5 000 smack rooney let's go
dude i i thought it was 500 that wasn't
paying attention no i actually put a
zero on it you're rich
okay if you kill two more people and
place third you'll get another dollar
on top of it dude i can't wait to get
that one dollar server shrink the zone
what are we doing what is this amateur
hour keep it going
that's a big one oh oh oh the sneak
attack oh zoom's going
oh oh all right four remaining zooms
you're insane
oh oh oh my god i'll assume
you can hear freaking 90s out there zuma
is that intimidating
oh cabo with the third party nico gets
away cobble third party what are you
doing
all right move zoom out zoom thank you
for coming up hey move all three of the
remaining people in here
there are three people left cobble green
bean
and nicos you all three are on the chat
the zone is still shrinking one of you
is walking away with 10 grand
want to use walk away at the honda civic
and one of you is walking away with a
dollar
this is big two of you are walking away
with 10 grand and one of you isn't and
you're about to decide who is it wait
time out time out time out i don't know
if it's fair yet don't shoot each other
nico's aren't you the one with the
netherright sword
yes okay i'm gonna give another eight
tour to everybody else good luck guys
pvp is on all right the circle is
shrinking
crank those 90s bro on a scale of one to
ten how nervous are you guys
my heart's beating harder than it's ever
been 21.
yo that's nine plus ten oh my god green
bean kind of like
pigeon hold himself all right cobbles
going on the offensive all right kabul
wants it
green beans said i either want a civic
or 10k but i'm not taking a dollar
yeah green beans perfectly content with
just letting one of them die
oh [ __ ] watch out oh oh oh no no
no i even i even told him oh my god no
way you just did that oh nico no
that was fun good try nico hey you you
had a dollar more than you would have
had if you didn't play
wait so we basically automatically at
least won a car uh
yes now whoever dies next gets a car and
then that person who killed
him gets oh wow i'm getting wrecked yeah
greet me run away run away oh my god
congratulations playing minecraft you
just won
ten thousand dollars on a tuesday
afternoon look at that
oh my god you guys are pvp guys actually
i don't think i won a single fight
during that
congratulations combo on ten thousand
dollars and congratulations green bean
on not winning green beans but winning a
honda civic
video is ending in four seconds what do
you want to say thank you
so much this is insane